but the fact that matters it is now
practical practical to build a business
online for Xero true dollar-cost purely
through sweat equity because what we'll
probably end up talking about more than
anything today and where I bet you a lot
of questions come from is really
breaking down why word of mouth is
really what we're talking about here see
word of mouth if you've ever taken any
classic marketing classes I'm sure
you've seen the stats word of mouth is
what builds businesses you know the half
a trillion dollars that all these
companies in the world spend on
marketing convert by best numbers at the
12 to 13 percentile so of all the money
you spend on those commercials and
direct mail and you know billboards and
radio ads 12 percent 12 percent
conversion
whereas word-of-mouth depending on the
study creeps into the low 70s so if
you're funny or girlfriend rolls up on
you and says hey you need to go see this
movie or you need to try out this new
makeup company and you can afford it
you're gonna do it seven to eight out of
ten times that's nuts and that's
everything that I focus on